[Applause]  I've been working on this movie for  almost 15 years I wanted to show what  really happened during this time the  extremes to which they lived and work  and partied is something you would not  expect from 1920s  don't worry about that  acquired by real events take two frames  off the tail and three more of that  Damien as a director pushes himself his  crew and the art he's creating to a  whole other level  foreign  the way that he tells stories is so  meticulous and precise because Damien so  many things going on at once there's no  CG Damien did in the camera this is  something that very few people can pull  off the moving pictures magic tricks  Damien is an auto he is one of the  greats of Our Generation  it's whether it's researching writing  the screenplay shooting he's just  extremely ambitious  I was lucky to have this amazing team  helped me to get this insane early  Hollywood Vision onto the screen  foreign  [Music]